1100 km/h
Ça va très vite !
C'est la vitesse à laquelle se déplace Paris
pendant que la Terre tourne sur elle-même.
Au niveau de l'équateur, c'est pire !
Celles et ceux qui habitent en Guyane
et qui sont en train de découvrir
cette "capsule de déconfiné"
se déplacent à environ 1650 km/h
et pourtant, on ne sent rien.
C'est étrange... Quand on est à bord d'une voiture
et qu'on tend la main à l'extérieur,
on ressent le déplacement
c'est parce que le véhicule se déplace en traversant l'air ambiant.
On ressent les molécules qui composent l'air
s'écouler sur la peau.
Si on ne sent pas la Terre tourner, c'est tout simplement parce que l'atmosphère qui l'enveloppe
se déplace en même temps qu'elle.
Comme tous les corps qui nous entourent,
les molécules qui composent l'air sont attirées
vers le centre de la Terre par la force de gravitation.
Résultat, l'atmosphère reste scotchée
au plancher des vaches.
D'accord, mais cette vitesse vertigineuse,
pourquoi ne la ressentons nous pas ?
En fait, ce n'est pas la vitesse
que nous ressentons mais l'accélération.
Quand nous sommes à bord du TGV
nous ne sentons pas qu'il roule à 300 km/h,
en revanche, au départ, quand il accélère
nous sommes plaqués contre le siège
et nous en décollons au moment où il freine.
Comme la terre tourne sur elle-même
à une vitesse constante, nous ne sentons rien.
Et nous ne ressentons pas non plus la force centrifuge
car elle est beaucoup plus faible
que la force de gravitation,
qui nous plaque au sol.
J'espère que tout cela ne vous aura pas tourner la tête !
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfinés", n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
toutes celles des jours précédents,
j'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour
et pour être sûr de n'en louper aucune
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche
À demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés, mais mais on reste en lien !